what's funny so we recently did
something a few months ago and I was
trying to get daredevil season 3 stuff
out of him he's like nope nope and nope
but now so I've seen the first three
episodes of the season they're so well
done and one of the things I really
enjoy about this show and especially
this season is eric has just all the
characters are so well-rounded and
well-written talk a little bit about
Eric as a new showrunner and maybe what
he brought to the table um I I can't
bait I basically can't say enough good
things about Eric I was I mean it must
be so difficult to come in not only on a
second season but on a third season and
and run a show and Eric brought a level
of confidence and clear vision that I
think is really important but he also
was able to be open minded and I always
felt like my ideas were considered and
there were times where I bring something
to him and he would be like that's a
really good idea let's do that and
there'd be other times where I take an
idea to him and he'd be like that's
awful we're not doing that and that's I
just that in and of itself is I think
really really important that he can he's
so excited to have a job so it that
enthusiasm and enthusiastic showrunner I
think I've ever worked with you just
you're excited to do his stuff and he's
excited to do your stuff and it's just
yeah it kind of feeds off yeah I I think
probably we would probably a little
nervous because again we you feel like
you understand you know these these
characters voices very well after a
couple of years and so this question of
was he gonna get that we gonna read
these scripts and not recognize these
the way these people spoke and obviously
that was not the case at all I saw Eric
in the hallway we were geeking out about
the season and he mentioned to me that
you have like a full episode this season
that's a Karen Central thing so talk a
little bit about when you does does he
tell you early in the season hey we're
gonna do one that's just Karen and what
is it like when you get that script and
you're like wait a minute what I mean
Eric was really generous and I think he
sat down with each of us individually is
just like because he knew
we were nervous and so he told me that
we would be going into Karen's backstory
you know why picking up a gun and
shooting someone would have been sort of
in her wheelhouse and I you know I was
very excited about that and he took a
lot of the concerns I had because I had
to show runners previous to him that had
different ideas for those backstories so
each season I'm playing different things
and trying to make it all work with all
the different clues that we've had and
he had the same challenge every clue
that was dropped he had to lay into this
backstory but I did not know that it
would be an episode I thought maybe it
would be a little spread out throughout
the thing so when I saw that and that we
were really gonna do a deep dive I mean
I mean I was thrilled it was so much fun
shoot I have said this before and I will
continue to say it was two of the most
fun weeks of my career really I can see
it and we are you allowed to see which
episode it is so it's somewhere I am
she's not allowed somewhere between the
first episode last episode
exactly bro for all three of you um
what's a day or two from filming season
three that you will always remember is
there like one day that really sticks
out there is famiglia yeah is it episode
four yeah yeah I was that's a pretty
memorable two days right I'm not gonna
say anything on camera have you seen it
I'm watching it later today okay but I
was hurt someone named Erik in the
hallway said because I made it to
episode three that he said you're gonna
be very happy when you get to Episode
four because it takes on so some action
that you might be enjoying mm-hmm that's
what he said Yeah right and I can see by
the face that I will be very happy
so episode four for you yes okay I would
say I mean generally I've never
participated in a show that had this
kind of action work so anytime we were
doing you know anyone of you know a
number of big action kind of set pieces
that was really fun for me and knew and
I really loved you know it's not a
single day but the the training process
working with the stunt team the
choreography and then on the day you
know getting to
well and maybe it's with you or maybe
it's with you who knows just fighting
anyway but yeah that was it was a really
cool process and fun you know I think
kind of one of those like you know
childhood dreams when you're you know
like when I used to play you know army
or whatever with my little with my
brother was that kind of you know same
kind of feeling yeah I did I was able to
do a scene with Vincent this year and we
shot it during a huge blizzard so it was
like a half day because they wanted to
make sure everybody could get home
safely and things like that so you would
be outside and it's just this whiteout
roaring snow and then you'd come into
this like warm dark quiet little
soundstage and we did this crazy intense
scene for like eight hours and I don't
know it just felt like this perfect
metaphor in a way so I always remember
that kind of coming together when though
the scene you're referring to when we
read that at the at the read-through
yeah I remember thinking it's one of the
best written scenes it's very very it's
a great way to see yeah just like the
only scene I've ever been like I'm
really jealous that well I have a lot of
those four years I'll take one speaking
of Vincent and kingpin I love his work
as kingpin he brings such a gravitas and
he's [ __ ] good in the role sorry for
cursing but talk a little bit about
working with him because he that's I
think he's the Phaeton he's my favorite
and I think it's for most fans he's the
favorite villain if you will on all
these shows yeah I mean I would just say
the great thing about working with
Vincent is you know as guy's a kingpin
you don't have to do a lot of acting
when you're you know opposite him
because he he he is that in real life he
brings that gravitas as a human not just
as a as the character so I wonder if
he's there because when he's kind of
like cuz like when we die he was very
playful and a little flirty and kind of
like if he was very not kingpin when we
weren't rolling and I found that really
intriguing and interesting cuz it kept
me kind of like I was excited I was like
okay let's go with action cuz I'm sure
we were gonna bring you know like it
wasn't once
stained energy it was this kind of thing
so I I don't know maybe he tailors to
what he thinks me the scene needs there
I don't know is interesting because I
mean he's also very you know especially
coming into it this season you know
Vincent strikes a bit of a he cuts a bit
of an imposing figure so I was you know
a little kind of nervous about working
with him but he was on you know he's
such a warm funny and and really kind of
supportive guy that and then of course
then then that plays into the kind of
storyline as well which is I can't get
into too much but yeah it's you know I
get to have some some great scenes with
Vincent and and it's kind of playing
into that dynamic I have so many more
questions for you but I don't think I
can say them on camera I will just stop
there and say series he loved what I saw
so far cannot wait to see the rest of
thank you so much right here yeah nice
to see you
you